everyone is asking themselves is a
bitcoin etf gonna happen in 2022 well
before we answer that question let's
first ask ourselves why is it important
that a bitcoin etf could actually get
approved we can look at gold as a great
example in the eight years prior to the
gold etf gld being approved gold went up
about 16
16 in eight years but in the eight years
after the gold etf got approved gold
went up over 280 percent obviously that
gold etf had a massive impact that's
that line right there through the middle
of this chart and so ultimately what
does an etf do a spot etf allows for
much more capital to come into the
market when you have either a fixed
supply asset or a very very hard supply
asset then of course increased demand
means that the price must go up and we
saw that with gold and so that brings us
to the bitcoin etf everyone wants to
know is the united states going to
approve a bitcoin spot etf in 2022
around the world we've seen other
countries and other jurisdictions go
ahead and improve spot etfs here in the
united states we've approved bitcoin
futures etf but we still don't have the
bitcoin spot etf since november the sec
and other regulators they have not been
playing ball we've seen over six
different bitcoin spot etfs denied just
since november and yesterday what we saw
was fidelities bitcoin spot etf got
denied that's right regulators saying no
we're not going to allow it and so
ultimately what you can see here is in
red all of those are the bitcoin spot
etf applications that got denied all the
ones in blue these are the ones that are
awaiting approval most people are not
very optimistic about watching this
actually get approved even to the point
that there are memes on the internet the
grim reaper continues to move from
application to application taking them
out saying no you are denied no you may
not allow investors in the public
markets to get etf exposure to bitcoin
itself and so we've got this quote here
from fidelity what they said was while
we are disappointed by the outcome of
the sec's deliberations resulting in
today's disapproval order we reaffirm
our belief in market readiness for a
physical bitcoin exchange traded product
and look forward to continue constructed
dialogue with the sec it's exactly what
you would expect from a trillion dollar
asset manager that is working with
regulators trying to get it approved now
ultimately i think that a bitcoin spot
etf is well overdue in the united states
it's already available in other markets
and ultimately i think that it is a
superior product a superior way for many
people to get exposure to bitcoin rather
than the other publicly traded vehicles
today it allows for redemption it allows
for the prevention of discounts or
premiums to nav and ultimately it's a
product that a lot of investors
understand they have safety and they
have confidence in the etf structure and
so regulators at some point i do believe
will approve a bitcoin etf it'll be a
spot etf and what we will see is
billions and billions and billions of
dollars will rush into that product on
the day that it's actually approved but
the big question is when will it happen
i don't know the answer to that i don't
think that we'll see it in the first
half of 2022 maybe we get a little bit
more optimistic in the second half of
2022 and then as we get into 2023 and
2024 my confidence level rises
significantly it is time for a bitcoin
spot etf in the united states i think
regulators have the desire and the
aspiration to get one through they still
have some concerns and those that are
putting forward these applications
they'll work with the regulators to go
ahead and quell those concerns to
mitigate the risk and to ultimately give
the american investor the exposure to
this digital decentralized currency to
allow for them to actually get exposure
to a store of value that prevents the
undisciplined monetary and fiscal
policies from debasing their savings and
ultimately i think that the united
states bitcoin spot etf whoever actually
ends up getting their application
approved first it'll become the largest
bitcoin fund in the world and that my
friends is something to look forward to
because when you increase demand on a
fixed supply asset the bitcoin price is
going to explode upwards